Patient speech can become a clinician-ready draft when staff review stays in control.
The report surface should stay linear, visible, and easy to correct.
ASR transcribes, the LLM structures, and staff review turns the draft into usable intake.
The first bottleneck is a fragmented patient story before clinical reasoning begins.
Speech becomes useful when transcript, uncertainty, and missing questions travel together.
Healthcare AI is realistic when each tool owns the right workflow layer.
Clinical decision-making needs stronger validation than fluent medical text.
A useful clinical model is evaluated on the workflow job it claims to support.
General ability opens the path, but task adaptation and review data make it dependable.
The review decision node is the safety center of the whole architecture.
The system may prepare a review draft; clinical authority remains human.
The useful output is a checkable patient story with uncertainty and missing questions.
Trust comes from layered validation: ASR, structuring, review, workflow, and governance.
The next validation path is staff-reviewed intake support, not an autonomous AI doctor.